okay benches we're back and yes I got a
[ __ ] haircut I thought I'd clay
myself up I look like a [ __ ] like
headless horse for a while but now we'll
get back to it I'm ready to get my my
template again last game I got [ __ ]
jump scared with an insane screen
recalibration Trek and this game I guess
I'm excited to get my kit as well this
is January 9 operator was an earlier
defective model for something worse
Alex the Tison they're all working
against you lost yourself trust the
video you made we need to get the arming
keys and destroy Telos one before it's
too late
any back-end mimics enhance the chest
and in fact I'll take a spine clothing I
got a nail out sorry
so [ __ ] looks like they're charged I
don't know why I just don't [ __ ] go
heavy objects oh what a shocker
I don't have anything else Oh still now
I got good guy good race I go second
thank you
all right let's make some more
recyclable material if you know when I'm
in nine name okay doctor yeah that's
[ __ ] it I'm usually just [ __ ]
weapons like that that what is it
operator operator Joe um no mob do some
[ __ ] hacking where's the hacking shut
up
listen psionic yeah matches and what
else do I need
thanks good yeah [ __ ] did it
yes yes why is it lies in its marketing
hold on there we go now I go I know else
I could use for like one more month
hmm yeah I guess y'all was right special
okay let me hack this [ __ ] I'm a hack a
baby yeah yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it hurts me yeah yeah yeah yeah
alright that's excited it the question
you won't make it
yes
[Music]
thank you thank ya I like you now wait a
minute
these tunnels run the entire length of
the station
mostly conduit carrying the bare
necessities our water there but
operators also use its deliver supplies
from the cargo bay up to the Arboretum
given the small number of crew assigned
here I would expect type and presence to
be minimal as well but that's probably a
bad assumption can I bet what is that
again anything rocket anime
and I think that I get wherever
hello evidence Memphis
okay that was wet
right now if I sorry about that
what I thought is is that that
victim Alaia
look at that a crested Nest
okay
I take this
and said
[ __ ] is that
I need this guy
only five
now what happens if I throw a bucket
recycler charges
again there we go
wait
[Music]
[ __ ] cheddar [ __ ] getting our bike
[Music]
that's like this left pocket angry
more specimens required dad that's a -
complete what is that this time
I got throw something a test
shut that work
a flower
[ __ ] I need like an object
hey this guy
okay
[Music]
I'm not
my name
and I [ __ ] with that today
[Music]
okay okay down here
for some fun
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I think it's all acting so funny and
right yeah we're too close I shot
[ __ ] my controller locked up I couldn't
like change weapons oh yeah hold it
that's why spot shed
[Music]
out
now [ __ ] fly and I get in here
for you always mine
[Music]
and a medic sent you that is that
represents Teddy that pulse hit your
suit systems pretty hard it came from
the substation ahead there's a
magnetosphere around Talos one that
keeps the Sun from cooking your insides
hopefully the generator isn't dying for
your sake I'll be fine how's that guy
that's way
detective [ __ ] medbay
how do i how do I get in there
[Music]
huh second a hammock
[Music]
Langly Anders I kind of got security
difficulties lately right
tell me what happened okay I'm sorry I'm
I'm sorry
Anders went into the mag Kimber can test
one of the coils that's gonna flaking on
us I don't know what happened exactly
but - so pulse I think it comes to
minutes dude god I'm so sorry Laurel can
you get up to the Arboretum no Anders
had the keycard
okay got it listen just sit tight don't
go into that chamber I'm gonna find she
fellas are we're going to security in
your way
woman possible women
beep children flourish operate in five
four three two Bullock rappin
I'll get it [ __ ] up here
at our next best thing there sir
fully possible total set
women speak children loudly shockwave in
five four three plus two rooms
check a [ __ ] ballsack today I guess
I'll take that I guess
morning beep children cloudless
operating five four three
[Music]
[ __ ] it it's set
okay what is this do 5xs [ __ ] crazy
warning plasma shock wave
here's out socket now
yeah
not great what am I in out what's
happening
don't let them do this deed back right
now that I don't do the same in our
sense the entire type in ecology appears
to be centered around the creation of
this substance the original researchers
called it coral beautiful but we're not
sure what its purpose is it's never
spread outside the containment cylinder
until now we're okay well anyway where
am I [ __ ] license I got
this is exactly what I need
ever Wow
yeah
and there are one more example eyes
I get that waiver
hey has other side
okay
it's [ __ ] hear me okay
but that
ah
now you know - no sir
sir [ __ ]
I'm sorry
what is that thank you she's engineering
dilution the vault wasn't being
conquered everything the powerful has
been compromised it's about time for
them to finally say I'm not a compact
I'm doing the best I can
Micah this is security chief Eleazar can
you hear it so so [ __ ] you been
trying to patch into the PA Mike seems
in the cargo bay and those things are in
there too
they're crawling all over the station
check everything around you eat it with
a wrench
check the wrench first Sam he's right
these things smash every freestanding
thing and see if it comes back at you
get to a secure area and when you're
safe call me by a French rhyme
I'm sending you a secure contact all
right understood unless my transcribed
in the coulomb monitor officially having
that now I can look myself in are you
okay I'm just catching my breath so tell
me like I get safe then call
uh-huh
I got an experiment
[Music]
and a second mimics it okay okay
hey I Beretta can take the sail scraps I
can't I can't I just a big fan of else I
guess I've always been a big fan out
yeah well I can eat that pizza it's
organic [ __ ] let's go up fetches okay
uh-oh in this episode here so we'll show
a la posada I got a lot of work to do
okay thank you
Thank You Johnny Bench [ __ ] nn I hope
you have a great day thank you